[Music]
thank you oh thank this will help me
right
thank you very much thank you
there we go yeah
Sasuke and this is his album and you're
doing the promotion the old-fashioned
way
old-fashioned grouse listen to this
[Applause]
and that's pretty good that was fired
are you got your great thank you so much
thank you so much I get this a lesson
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
okay see you oh you know okay I'm doing
uh okay you think so no come on
yes what do you do what are you selling
i mimic stuff you mimic stuff yeah do we
can you duplicate yes sir you duplicate
what music there could be anything
anything they could be movies to be
music oh and I have a lot of
entertainers and spas like yourself
right they come and they say hey I
appreciate you keeping me alive
that's nice children so you you copy or
duplicate okay duplicate that's gonna
work yeah you gotta let it star you got
people like after seven huh look at that
you got the Saturday Night Fever
soundtrack right here the Bee Gees must
be very happy that you're I like ABBA
okay take a chance on me Janet on what
do you think is there any places in the
neighborhood I should check out up here
in Ireland you hungry yeah I got
Sylvia's
doesn't like Soviet it's not kosher oh
oh sorry did I
[Applause]
I want you to come to the show okay yeah
would you please come I'm gonna sit in
front I'm like you don't want to be up
front that's too much this is look at me
look at me up close it's not pretty I
want to be close to you what you need be
on the stage with me do you ever listen
to Abba ABBA you know ABBA
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
what's that see bad said I'm not helping
you at all you're fantastic
I need a picture that was very good
not go over coat when the wind blows
free take good care of yourself goodie
do you want that on your playlist so my
mom is going back home to my country
back Burkina Faso and okay to foster
yeah my I know because my brother in
law's from bikini Faso yeah we are
family and so they're traveling out
there and they want to bring okay let's
get your parents some t-shirts
we're on me this is a lot this is an old
Parliament right this this has been here
20 years ballers what is your name sir
Holly Holly and as your last name baller
family name my last name shot-caller
[Applause]
[Music]
this Harlem out okay oh no they don't
they don't even do them better but no
they don't need spork
oh they tore cuz that where I have my
butter yeah that's the one that's the
one with you I don't have any but
there's nothing back here
you're welcome to feel if you want but
we got it oh we gotta do that you went
to a great length then you went to such
great lengths no no we're not cutting
this out this is going in you like that
I love Harlem
yeah we're gonna buy a lot I'm Conan
O'Brien
why did you show my face means nothing
to you but my name down okay
you probably listen to me on the radio
I'm on TBS you ever watch TBS you won't
even look at me kind of a funny guy
couldn't you tell
something depressed me about our
conversations I'll be fine in a little
while it's gonna take about two days
days yeah I'll be happy again no I'm
gonna make you happy right now
what there you go Mike can I pull it off
yes especially with me on his side yeah
I got my shirts time to call my wife and
tell her it's over one yeah yes you know
it's hard enough talking to you hello I
get my hair what's that yes
[Applause]
why are you so happy to see
okay you braid is this gonna look good
on me
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
what'd you do
I look ridiculous
what if you were in a club and you saw
me dancing alone
[Music]
she's amazing
[Applause]
[Applause]
you